[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui mais la parole aux femmes
s'immiscent samedi puis cette semaine je
vais parler avec vous un sujet
extrêmement chaud très monde ici c'est à
dire toutes les situations qui se passe
présentement en nouvelle-écosse auprès
de la nation s'y pique nique asiatique
qui est une nation mig mois par rapport
à la pêche traditionnelle miglos versus
la pêche commerciale allochtone on a pu
voir une montée de la violence envers
les pêcheurs traditionnels on a vu des
bateaux entouré des bateaux de pêche
traditionnel big man et on a vu la
communauté des pêcheurs commercial se
faire justice
brûler les entrepôts des pêcheurs mean
man on a vu des bâches à clous et des
clous sur des planches pour 3 crever les
pneus de certains des pêcheurs vendent
sur leur camion et on a aussi vu
l'inaction de la grc face à certaines de
ces actions là en disant ah ben c'est
pas notre problématique ou même le
responsable des communications
ouais mais nous on essaie de comprendre
les deux côtés de la question en tout
cas la problématique autour de soucier
que ça continue de faire ressentir et
ressortir l'ignorance du canada autour
de ce qui est l'enjeu des droits
ancestraux des droits de pêche des
droits de chasse des droits de sont
reconnus par traiter aussi qu'ils sont
tenus par les communautés autochtones un
peu partout cad
c'est plus facile d'avoir une
compréhension de la loi sur les indiens
puisque la loi sur les indiens cette une
loi assez englobant qui faisait un peu
un paquet monolithique d1 et d'y
inscrire donc c'est une loi qui s'est
acquitté de façon unilatérale sur toutes
les communautés mais les droits
ancestraux des droits issus de traités
bien ce sont des droits qui sont portées
de façon individuelle par chaque commune
au pin par chaque nation les droits des
innus ne sont pas les droits des minois
ne sont pas les droits des mots à
certains de ses droits
ça ressemble puisqu'on avait des
pratiques qui étaient dans un ensemble
quand même reconnaissable pêche chasse
cependant quand on rentrait dans des
sujets tels que la pêche commerciale
chez les minimes la pêche du homard mais
là on rentre dans des sujets qui des
fois son très difficile pour les
canadiens et déjà un commerçant de
comprendre puisque ces droits ancestraux
sont issus d'une pratique continue et
n'a jamais été arrêtées depuis le début
de la colonisation jusqu'à aujourd'hui
et dans le code des pêches commerciales
et bien c'est qu'il y avait une idée
comme quoi les communautés d'accueil ne
faisait pas de commerce on n'avait pas
de d'échangés commerciaux qui existait
avant l'arrivée des européens qu'on a
commencé à échanger des verreries pis
débit casserole alors que ce n'était pas
le cas on d'échangés poissons du tabac y
avait un commerce y avait un passage qui
se faisait de nation à nation et ça
permettait justement une circularité
temps des ressources sur le territoire
très différents impôts de toutes les
nations avaient des droits de pêche
commerciale ou de d'échangé commercial
tels que le tabac cependant il existe
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
faire reconnaître et respecter c'est un
processus très long très coûteux et très
prenant pour les communautés et là on
pense beaucoup à l'article 35 de la
constitution de 1982 qui reconnaît les
droits ancestraux mais on pense pas
souvent aux arrêts qui sortent des cours
suprêmes à chacun pour pouvoir de hockey
tels droits vous l'avez reconnu il le
chili mythe moi c'est la démarche
lorsqu'ils sorti en 1999 qui
reconnaissait le droit des pains chauds
mais moi de pouvoir gagner leur vie de
façon modeste à travers la pêche
commerciale
il a bien la frustration en les pêcheurs
commerciales et les pêcheurs
traditionnels autochtones puisque ce ne
sont pas les mêmes cadres qui englobe la
pêche
chez les minimes ans que chez les
échanges commerciaux et la vieille la
frustration de bella on a des droits
nous soucie aurons reçu les lois on les
respecte et de l'envié
aussi certaines de ces actions qui sont
très brutal envers les communautés
autochtones
il faut comprendre que le droit de
gagner sa vie de vie de façon modeste 6
kw à ckoi modeste qu'est-ce qu'on a le
droit de gagner nous quand on regarde
les revenus annuels des pêcheurs mines
moi je pense qu'il tourne entre 50000 et
100000 $ annuellement mais si on va dans
des pêcheurs commerciaux ça peut aller
d'un quart de million de dollars a revu
une millions $ annuellement la page
en plus étant une activité de chance
parce qu'à chaque année tu peux avoir
une bonne ni une mauvaise année m'ont
pas empêché le crabe de façon
commerciale et je me souviens que
c'était vraiment chaque année c'était au
temps différent et que ça pouvait créer
beaucoup de compétition auprès des
pêcheurs pour les meilleurs endroits
pour le numéro alors pu imaginer devoir
des pêcheurs mingoua aller de l'avant''
trouver les endroits et pêcher cependant
on s'entend que modeste c'est pas c'est
parce qu'il faut mettre en danger
l'économie des pêcheurs commerciaux et
c'est là que se rajoutent pas ce que
c'est on parle de compétition entre de
deux travailleurs l'on rajoute ce fameux
racisme ordinaire et ou racisme
systémique parce que le racisme
ordinaire celui de ne pas vouloir voir
des autochtones gagnent bien leur vie
des autochtones développer une économie
qui les sortirait d'une certaine tombe
pauvre piqué décret par le système de la
loi sur les indiens par exemple et de la
colonisation
mais le racisme systémique ou si c'est
de dire mais modeste sur mes modestes le
droit de vivre de gagner leur vie où ils
ont droit de gagner leur vie de façon
modeste
alors vous comprenez qu'on garde un cap
sous le droit de gagner sa vie
communautaire d'acton ce qui donne bien
pour nous c'est que on a une pratique
traditionnelle quitterait en respect
avec la ressource à s'assurer qu'un
pérennité des ressources
cependant
on utilise aussi certains des discours
de conservation contre les pêcheurs dit
mais là si on veut conserver la
ressource faut pas pêcher à ce moment à
neuf au possible et on va utiliser ce
discours us était très très très négatif
à travers les années puisque on a
souvent utilisé le discours de la
conservation pour empêcher les
communautés d'aller pêcher chasser de
gagner leur manger quotidien angoissées
pour conserver les ressources alors ça
ça des faits des années le travail aussi
existent entre les communautés et
certains des milieux de protection du
territoire puisque on va entendre ça
comme étant une manière de nous empêcher
de pouvoir quand ils minent notre
quotidien notre pays notre manger manger
de façon traditionnelle
alors tout ça se mélange dans une
poudrière de tensions raciales de
tension historique aussi puisque le
traité de 752 qui existent en nouvelle
écosse se reconnaissaient le droit parce
qu'un traité d'amitié en effet le droit
des minois de pêcher de chasse et de
faire des échanges commerciaux
alors je vous dis que beaucoup de gens
me dire leur effort en venir c'est vieux
maître était là mais aucun n'a le droit
existant que il n'a pas été abolie et ce
droit existe encore pour les communautés
autochtones mais là ça rajoute une autre
couche pour certaines réparations qui
existent par rapport à l'identité qu'on
appelle des métiers de l est et le
metalist vont souvent même et des
allophones qui vont commencer à trouver
leurs ancêtres autochtone pour penser
d'aller clairement des droits de pêche
ancestrale qui ne seront pas connecté à
la communauté qui ingèrent le territoire
pour s'assurer que les pêcheurs
mouvements traditionnels respecter
ressources non c'est comme une
incompréhension mais en même temps ils
ne cessent de prise des droits
ancestraux et une espèce de deux façons
de faire disparaître ses droits le qui
sont des droits qui sont portés par les
personnes qui n'ont jamais étaient gens
on n'a pas perdu la guerre c'est ça une
mondiale vous êtes en arrière cagan on
ne pas perdre du gard ont des alliés on
a signé des traités
on s'est fait reconnaître nos droits
dans extrêmement chaud comme sujet
extraits
me dis que c'est le mélange en plus avec
des identités traditionnels ou des loups
d'identité même administrative qui vont
servir ensuite à défaire des droits
ancestraux et ne pas reconnaître
justement la tension qui existe dans les
communautés par rapport à avoir le droit
d'exister de vivre peut-être plus que de
façon modeste
donc c'est chaud ça ressemble beaucoup à
ce qu'on a pu voir aussi avec les ouates
souhaitait nhtsa doit beaucoup de
tension d'incompréhension et des
canadiens qui découvre justement des
droits se trouvent des communautés
autochtones
alors n'hésitez pas à partager cette
vidéo et n'hésitez pas non plus à donner
des commentaires toujours constructif
s'il vous plaît on a déjà assez de des
chicanes sont pleins d'autres sujets
mais vous comprendrez que c'est
difficile et que ça doit aller de
l'avant puisque ont fait appel
écumer le 2 si la problématique alors je
fais une belle semaine c'est sur cet
enjeu là avec le hashtag prize en ligue
mardi et plusieurs autres mots clés qui
vont vous servez à comprendre les enjeux
des communautés